[Music]  hi everybody i'm lauren zima on Episode  three of The Bachelor we got crazy with  Corinne I have a little surprise land up  my sleeve  yes Corinne brought some whipped cream  what are you doing take it off for some  tears I feel so stupid no Nick and I  just honestly do not even have a chance  and some slumber to the bachelor mansion  Corinne is missing at the rose ceremony  so this episode was pretty much all  about Corinne she was trying to sleep  with Nick I definitely know how to turn  on the sex charm the ladies were not  happy about it  tensions are starting to rise and even  the Backstreet Boys could not upstage  Corinne listen to her commentary on what  choreography is plan dancing is one of  like being dancing what is it called  corner yeah so we're all developing a  little bit of a love-hate relationship  with Corinne I want to know what you  guys think  how much longer will she last on the  show let me know over on Twitter  [Music]  you